wir beginnen mit den heftigen streit bei
einer bekannten influenza in mit
influenza und reality stars ehrlich
gesagt sondern da kann ich mich
allerdings nicht so aus du kennst nicht
georgia flocken
nicht schon früher ich kenne mich auch
mit interessenten erst seit heute auf
instagram seit diese sendung gestartet
ist aber und habe ich glaube die
überwältigende zahl von 30 verloren oder
so um liebe zuschauer von sie jetzt
thomas kirchhoff instagram bin gespannt
was es bewirkt aber die
380.000 oder sogar über 380.000 follower
von georgina wirst du wahrscheinlich
nicht so schnell erreichen sind
allerdings gar nicht mal so schöne
schlagzeilen die giardina da macht
zurzeit belegt exklusiv ein video von
einer sehr blutigen auseinandersetzung
zwischen der hochschwangeren und ihrem
ex verlobten kubilay vor der vater ihres
ungeborenen
babys ja und wir sehen es rote flecken
im teppich blutgetränkte taschentücher
ein beschmierte seehofer wirklich ein
schockierendes video das die
dramatischen ausmaße einer
auseinandersetzung zeigen
jacobi ist handgreiflich geworden wir
nehmen es an im mai ist es zu diesem
heftigen streit zwischen dem tv
sternchen und dem unternehmer in dubai
gekommen übrigens auch nicht das erste
mal dass es zwischen zwischen den beiden
knallt aber so erschreckende bilder der
verwüstung haben wir wirklich noch nicht
gesehen und wir haben es vielleicht auch
gerade gehört eine weibliche stimme sagt
im hintergrund da wollte wohl jemanden
mein baby umbringen und nach
bild-informationen kam in der nacht an
sogar noch die polizei nahm die gina und
ihrem extra die pässe appiah und über
dieses video wollen müssen wert sprechen
mit unserer bildershow chefin giannina
kirsch janina wir haben damals im mai
schon berichtet aber wir kannten gar
nicht dieses dramatische ausmaß was
weißt du heute zu diesen bildern herr
sandra das ausmaß war und so wirklich
nicht bekannt diese bilder sind ja
wirklich verstörend also diese blutspur
zieht sich vom wohnzimmer bis ins
schlafzimmer
alles liegt auf dem boden alles ist
verwüstet das sieht eher aus wie nach
einem gefecht nach einem kampf und nicht
wie nach einem beziehungsstreit also ich
weiß nicht wie es bei dir ist aber bei
mir als die nach einem streit die zum
glühen ich glaube nämlich so aus aber
was wir wissen ist dass kubilay an dem
tag die beiden haben ja gemeinsam im
dubai gelebt zu der zeit in einem
schicken apartment komplex in downtown
kubilay war in deutschland ist an dem
tag zurückgekommen soll sich dann im
flieger in der first class ordentlichen
drink genehmigt haben und wohl auch gut
angetrunken gewesen sein als er dann in
dubai georgina ankam es soll dann zu
einem wahnsinnigen streit gekommen sein
handgreiflichkeiten soll es gegeben
haben wie gesagt dieses ergebnis sehen
wir hier auf diesem verstörenden video
dann kamen die polizei er wurde von
sicherheitskräften abgeführt hast du
denn irgendeine vermutung oder weißt du
mehr dazu von wem ist das blut also ich
meine attackiert ein mann die frau die
ja eigentlich liebt und die ein kind von
ihm in sich trägt
es ist eine grausame vorstellung
allerdings muss man sagen da steht
tatsächlich aussage gegen aussage
sie sagt er habe sie angegriffen und er
sei betrunken vor ihrer tür gestanden
und ist dann aggressiv geworden sie
hätte nur versucht sich zu beschützen
sich und ihr kind er wiederum sagt sie
hat sie angegriffen und zwar mit einem
brotmesser also da steht einfach
wirklich aussage gegen aussage
sie hat dann auch mal zu uns gesagt dass
sie ihm dass er die polizei gerufen hat
und dann versucht hat sich als opfer
darzustellen
das klingt ja fast schon ein bisschen so
als würde sie ihm unterstellen dass er
sich die wunden selbst zugefügt
also hier aussage gegen aussage aber
nichtsdestotrotz zeigt es einfach wie
toxisch diese basieren zwischen den
beiden ist also dass es so weit kommt
dass wir blutflecken sehen dass sich das
ein paar aufeinander los geht wer auch
immer nun am ende derjenige war der
angegriffen hat das ist einfach schlimm
und wirklich furchtbar und bei den
beiden dingen natürlich auch die nerven
am ende werden sie natürlich auch
gestern noch einmal angerufen sind ja
mei von todesangst gesprochen und jetzt
gestern war sie einfach wieder völlig
verzweifelt und sagte dann hat auch er
sei psychisch gestört und sie möchte
nichts mehr mit ihm zu tun haben sie
wollte heute nicht mit uns sprechen kann
vielleicht auch nicht so schwanger aber
du hast jemand eingeladen der die sehr
gut kennt exakt und zwar habe ich ja
eben gerade schon gesagt das ist im
flugzeug dazu gekommen sein soll dass er
sich betrunken hat und ein mann der
dabei war das ist timo berger und den
würde ich jetzt gerne dazu holen der
kann uns natürlich einiges über diesen
tag noch berichten hallo herr berger
eine wunderschöne nebenher welches
gerade schon gesagt sie waren dabei mit
kubilay im flieger von deutschland nach
dubai erzählen sie uns doch mal wie das
in dem flieger so abgelaufen ist also
erst mal war es überhaupt für mich ein
bisschen mit schuld weil ich ja auch
schon am nächsten tag das mitbekommen
habe wie das eskaliert ist dort unten
und ironischerweise hatte emirates
kubilay erst gar nicht die bordkarten
wir wollen für den flieger weil er kein
prozess dabei hatte und dann habe ich
mit dem vorgesetzten gesprochen dass er
noch mal ein auge zudrücken sollte und
wir das klären und so kann man überhaupt
essen den flieger er war gebucht den
economy hat er mitbekommen dass wir
wissen es fliegen und er wollte auch
unbedingt an der bar mit trinken und hat
dann im flieger dann in das
entsprechende update gemacht und wie man
ja den bildern sieht haben wir dann dort
den flug genossen ich wusste aber nicht
dass das letztendlich dazu führt dass er
sturzbetrunken sechs stunden später
aussteigt und nicht mehr herr seiner
sinne ist herberger können sie sich denn
vorstellen dass kubilay da so
handgreiflich wurde oder was was glauben
sie
ich glaube wir die kolleginnen was schon
sagte ist 50 50 wahrscheinlich kommen
zwei welten aufeinander und
kubilay war eben extrem betrunken als er
morgens ortszeit dubai 6000 flieger ist
ich denke da waren auch noch andere
sachen im spiel und
man kann nicht sagen wer letztendlich
den auslöser gestartet hat aber man
sollte dringend dafür sorgen dass die
beiden personen nicht mehr aufeinander
treffen papa sagen sie hat er dann
irgendwas auf diesem flug über georgina
erzählt über das verhältnis wir alle
wissen dass das immer sehr angespannt
war es gab viele trennungen auch
zwischendurch dann gab es einen
gerichtstermin letztes jahr war sie ihn
angezeigt hat weil er angeblich
handgreiflich ihr gegenüber geworden ist
das ist auch immer noch nicht
abgeschlossen dieses verfahren hat er
denn irgendwas zu dem verhältnis zu
georgina erzählt ihnen gegenüber
also eigentlich hatte ich den eindruck
nachdem man ja die presse verfolgt hatte
dass es da wieder sehr viel stress gab
und ich gehe auch verwundert war dass er
wieder hin fliegt er zeigte mir dann den
prozessverlauf mit der gene dann alles
in ordnung guck mal hier ich soll noch
tabletten mitbringen und sie schrieb
baby ich freue mich und alles wirkte
sehr harmonisch und man konnte fast
glauben okay die schwangerschaft kommt
jetzt in der heißen phase vielleicht
raufen sich zusammen
aber dann wenige stunden später waren
dann eines besseren belehrt
vielen dank timo berger für diese erste
erkenntnisse zu diesem video was
allerdings schon im mai aufgenommen
wurde vielen dank janina was was glaubst
du timo berger hat gesagt das ist immer
ein auf und ab du weißt es auch glaubst
du wirklich dass jetzt schluss ist also
ich meinen sohn baby verändert ja noch
mal einige ist es ja klar und dann fühlt
man sich wieder zugehörig vielleicht und
verträgt man sich nochmal oder glaubst
du das war es definitiv zwischen man
sagt ja immer pack schlägt sich pack
verträgt sich aber ich denke für die
beiden wäre es besser wenn das ganze
einfach beendet wird vor allen dingen
auch für das kind denn ich hatte es eben
schon angedeutet es gibt einen verfahren
weil sie ihn angezeigt hat wegen
körperlicher gewalt sie hat die anzeige
dann wieder zurückgezogen trotzdem wird
ermittelt und er hat damals auch vor
gericht eingestanden dass er ein
alkoholproblem hat auf der anderen seite
jeder georgina fleur kennt weiß dass die
extrem aufbrausend ist und auch kein
blatt vor mund nimmt und auch schon den
einen oder anderen skandal in ihrer
karriere hatte also hier treffen
scheinbar zwei charaktere aufeinander
die sehr extrem sind und nun kann man
immer sagen solange die beiden nur damit
zurechtkommen müssen ist das natürlich
auch nur deren angelegenheit aber jetzt
ist ein kind im spiel und ich würde mir
einfach für die beiden wünschen dass sie
ihren streit bei seite legen können
damit das kind nicht in so einen
riesengroßen zoff mit reingezogen
china erlebt ja in dubai die geburt
steht kurz bevor weißt du ob wie auch im
land hast du da irgendwelche
informationen aktuell soll georgina in
deutschland sein so haben es uns freunde
berichtet es soll ihr großer wunsch sein
das kind hier zur welt zu bringen sie
erwartet ja eine tochter in dubai ist
das auch tatsächlich nicht so ganz
einfach für unverheiratete frauen ein
kind zu bekommen es droht eine
abschiebung ist rot gefängnisstrafe es
gab da jetzt in den letzten monaten
reformen reformen die man einführen
möchte trotzdem ist das alles ein sehr
heikles thema man braucht eigentlich den
partner an seiner seite der muss mit
unterschreiben im krankenhaus sonst
bekommen die mütter keine geburtsurkunde
und das ist wahrscheinlich auch mit ein
grund warum sie das kind gerne hier zur
welt bringen möchte kubilay soll laut
unseren informationen in istanbul sich
derzeit aufhalten bei unserer familie
und ob er bei der geburt dabei sein wird
steht in den sternen das ist jetzt auf
jeden tag jeden fall all zu weit wir
wünschen georgina auf jeden fall alles
gute finden auf jeden fall eine
anstrengung auf jeden fall und danke dir
dass du hier bei uns aus
[Musik]